c'est ici derrière moi que vendredi 30
avril s'est tenue la cérémonie d'hommage
national à stéphanie m'enfermer cette
agente administrative de la police a été
assassiné une semaine plus tôt à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici au
commissariat de police de rambouillet où
elle travaillait depuis 1993 l'émotion
était vive ici cet hommage national a
été présidée par le premier ministre et
jean castex en présence d'autres
ministres et secrétaires d'état ainsi
que des élus du territoire sa famille
était également présente sur place une
cérémonie sobre et républicaine ici sur
la place andré thomas jean castex s'est
exprimé il a rendu hommage à stéphanie
mon fermé s'il a qualifié de serviable
et doté d'un caractère heureux inutile
de dire qu'elle était toujours accueilli
à bras ouverts dans ce commissariat dans
lequel elle travaillait depuis le début
de sa carrière en 1993 où chacun la
connaissait et où elle était un peu
comme chez elle elle était d'ailleurs
partout chez ed à rambouillet
après cette prise de parole stephanie
m'enfermer a reçu la légion d'honneur à
titre posthume
une minute de silence a également été
respectée par l'ensemble des personnes
sur place
après la marseillaise la famille à
quitter les lieux accompagné des
politiques sur un titre de bonnie tyler
[Musique]
ja
c'était une très jolie cérémonie qui
était digne qui était simple et qui à
mon avis ressembler
à stéphanie je crois que c'est bien que
la la république se soit déplacé chez
elle que la république se soit déplacé
comme ça dans ce territoire rural de
l'île de france
ce petit bout de france rambouillet qui
a été tellement traumatisée par cet
attentat
tellement bouleversée c'est un éclair
dans un ciel bleu autour de cette place
il y avait aussi des habitants la ville
avait installé un écran géant pour
qu'ils puissent assister à la cérémonie
on écoute leurs réactions c'est une
policière qui s'est fait tuer quelqu'un
qui représente la france qui nous dit
nous qui nous défend tous les jours et
de me dire que quelqu'un lui a ôté la
vie c'est s'attaquer à la france et
c'est pour ça que je suis ici pour lui
rendre hommage à montrer à ses proches
que ben a mérité en fait cet ogre
endommagé que tous ces gens soient
l'enfer émouvant un très beau discours
très bien très bien
j'ai mon père qui en fait police et donc
je voulais être là aussi pour lui et
c'est un comment dire c'est à un moment
aussi qui je pense doit tous nous
rassembler et faire en sorte va de ne
pas tomber face à ça comme on l'a
entendu ce qui est sûr c'est que cet
acte terroriste a marqué les
rambolitains ainsi que l'ensemble de la
nation
ils n'oublieront jamais stéphanie
m'enfermer